I don't think it.
Hey, Kaila, how are you?
Good morning, not too bad or afternoon, probably evening for you.
It's 11.30 in the night.
You can call it evening. But the good thing is in this hot, hot, hot summers, where the temperatures were reaching around 40, 42 degrees, we had a very good rain. And now the temperature might have dropped to around 26, 28 degrees.
Yeah.
In the day as well, it was like 32 degrees. So the temperature dropped down well below and pleasant and cool and it's really soothing. So Manuj was saying to me, like Mark was saying to me, like, let me go outside the hand room. I said, no. When I cannot, you also cannot.
Okay.
Yeah.
But.
Uhh...
How's the weather over there?
Uh, starting to heat up again.
I think this weekend we're hitting 30.
Oh.
Getting up there.
So, what's the maximum temperature that reaches there in Canada?
Um...
Earlier, I was on Reddit and they had a post of the highest temperatures in Canada. And in 2021, there was a place in my province in BC here that hit 49.6.
which is extreme. It's not normal, but that's like the hottest it's been. Absolutely insane. Usually we'll get up to around 30, around where I live, sometimes 32 is usually the maximum. And it doesn't last too long.
Yes.
Thank you.
That's great.
32 is for us as well. It's bearable. It's actually good in summers because it can reach more than 50 normally.
I don't like anything over 25.
Because once you hit 25, then even the breeze starts to get warm and I'm like, no, I'm just going to go in the air conditioning now. Thank you.
So...
Yeah.
Or, uh, Kaila, how are the things looking like on your end?
We're doing pretty good. Had a nice chat with one of the TLs this morning about the EPDR project. Apparently we're scaring people. Because, yeah, after I see them during the day, they're phoning and going, hey, we need to get in your computer, work on your...
antivirus.
But the users, they don't know the after-hours tags. They're very particular about who they deal with, so...
Correct.
They're like, oh, we'll call you back. And honestly, I think that's a great response from the users because it means they're actually security aware. So.
I take that as a win. It just makes it a little difficult for us to deal with all the EPDR stuff.
Yeah.
Yeah, but in this case, like the shift rotates and everything, and you can just let the ISTs know, like they can let the customers know, like these are the techs from after hours who are working specifically on EPDR projector or anything, and they might call you for updating the antivirus or...
working on them so it's a legit call from F12 to secure your systems. Kind of an automated email which can go from F12 to all the users whose EPDR devices are pending to be updated. So maybe that can help. And there's one more thing, Kyle.
Yeah.
We can do a backstage work as well in this or we need to take control of the computer.
At the point we're at now, a lot of it does need us to take control. Some of it, we can backstage it. We do have automations for automatically pushing it. We're starting to run out of the missing tickets, which is a good thing. We're getting everything deployed.
Yep.
But once we get into the failures, a lot of those will need direct intervention. A lot of them will be just a reboot of the device, but some are going to need to have the antivirus removed and reinstalled, which is going to be a lot of scheduling.
Honestly, we can probably pass some of that over to the ISTs to go, hey, we need to schedule a time, leave it on, because they will need a reboot, very likely. So we can schedule the user to leave the device on overnight. We can get the night guys to do it, or maybe even schedule it during people's lunch breaks.
So there's going to be some back and forth on the failures, but we're working through it.
Yeah, we have seen that in the previous project when Manuj was not in, what was that project? I forgot that there was a lot of through.
I do not remember which was the last project. Not firewalls. There was one more project between the firewalls and the CPDR, I guess.
Mm.
Firewalls.
The NSM, the Sonic Wells in the portal.
I.
We have a VNSM portal.
So we were adjusting.
Okay.
I was using the portal. No, that's right. We had to change a lot of passwords because there was the breach with the backups. Sonic was online backups.
Yes.
Correct.
Yeah.
That will, and there also we saw a lot of to and pro, and so Kyle, when we have these projects coming in and there might be other projects coming in, so my future state goals in like, how can we build a process so that it becomes easy? I know.
that users are very familiar with the takes of the ISDs and everything. But how we do make it easy for our after our takes is this is 1 project. Maybe some other thing comes in and maybe they say like the updates are not getting installed and you, your team needs to take care of that.
No.
In that case, again, we would have to connect with the users and get their machines rebooted and everything and maybe fix the patches issues and everything. So in that case, again, we'll see these pushbacks coming in from the users. So we need to put in some process in place where the users know.
Like these are the after hours tech team or maybe the ISTs inform like we have one more team who works centrally for all the regions and everything and they might contact you and these are the users in those teams.
Yeah.
Something like that.
Yeah, that's probably what's going to have to happen down the road a bit, because if they're needing to talk to people, we can't, like there's, for the IC that we were talking about this morning, there's 35 tickets, and it's not something that we can just dump on them. They don't want it. We don't want to dump it to them because we want to deal with it ourselves.
Correct.
And we cannot do it.
So...
Getting the...
Getting the end users up to speed with, hey, you're going to get a call from these people. It's fine. It's likely going to be something we're going to be doing down the road.
One question, Kaila, I would like to ask because I'm not knowledgeable about this. Are these users available on Teams with us? Like suppose any end declined which is there, are they available on Teams with us?
Some of them might be.
I don't want to set the precedence with end users that we reach out through Teams because we have had issues where threat actors have reached out through Teams. So doing it that way, then they start going, oh, well, it's fine because F12 does this. We don't want that as a communication method that end users.
I got it.
And then they start interacting only on Teams.
No, got it, that's.
That's totally a valid and fair point.
Like, we do.
We do end up talking to end users sometimes on Teams if it's something we need to chat back and forth with them, but we don't need to actually be on a phone call. We might, after the initial phone call, we might set up, hey, we're just going to talk to your Teams. Keep an eye out for messages from me. We'll work through this and get to a solution.
But, as a...
Uh...
as a general communication.
Not something we want them to get used to.
Okay, this again lands me with a very big question in my mind. Like if the users are rejecting because of the security reasons. Now, when they are connecting with F12 win offers, these users would again connect to someone non-familiar.
Correct, but they're calling into F12, so it's not a...
So, wouldn't that raise it?
Correct.
Okay, alright.
call of, hey, we want to jump into your device. And honestly, I want to just tell them, hey, if it comes from F12, it's fine, but it's so easy to spoof a number that I would rather that they be cautious.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, that's totally correct. The approach is totally right. I was just trying to explore so that I could give my ideas and suggestions. I usually do not discuss all these things with Mark on a day-to-day basis because I want to keep coming up with fresh ideas, otherwise he would.
Mm.
Mm-hmm.
overload my mind with his thoughts and I do not want to portray the same thoughts here. Yeah.
He might be saying like, oh, I have already done this communication with Kyle. Why is he doing that again? But maybe a new flavor that I want to bring into.
All good.
Yes.
Nope.
Absolutely.
Yeah, let's start with the presentation. I have a lot of things to discuss because this time Mark has really helped me in building a good presentation because of his excellent data.
So agenda stays the same. Key change means like the service delivery was stable. Overall, we saw a reduced missed call. It has gone up way too high. And today, during our strategy meet in the morning,
Manuj showed, sorry, I keep switching between Manuj and Mark. So Manuj showed like the numbers in December were around 79 missed calls and this quarter when we see, it's down to 78 to 37. That's...
What, and that's a great achievement reduction in 50% of the missed calls, and plus we have engineers who are transitioned in new and...
This is definitely a stronger point that I see and what I see mainly is team moving towards consistency. That's going great. So Manish told me like there haven't been any escalations in the recent times. All things are going good.
Yes.
So that's also good, like volume increase, but missed call wins down, no escalation, that's going good. Overall CSAT that I see is 97% for the last month. It could have been 100, but there was one DSAT for Sarah and only one DSAT, one. Yeah, and I understand and.
Mm.
Yeah, there's the one for Sarah and...
I looked at it, I'm like, well, like it's a recurring issue, so that's probably most of what triggered the VSAT. But at the same time, when I listened to the calls, she was a little slow, and it was probably her first time dealing with that part of the auth point.
Yeah.
So I don't fault her for being slow. She was cautious. She got to the resolution.
User's a little unhappy. We kept that one with her, but I don't see it as a problem. Like, I'm not concerned that she got that desat.
Yeah.
Yeah. Overall, we see a greater utilization across the team. It's not only one tech, every tech is achieving a high utilization. So that's great. Even when we are running with one person less, we are running 24 cross 7 operations. We have an interview scheduled today.
So hopefully he should be a good, yeah, hopefully he should be a good fit. I have seen him. He's in Chandigarh itself. I think he has worked with Mark before in his previous assignment, or maybe not. I'm just skeptical because can be.
Yep, right after this meeting.
So overall, key improvements, shift coverage is optimized. We are seeing the heat map and everything, and based on that, we are optimizing our shift. And the weekend support is also enhanced. Missed call tracking, and what I got to know from Mark is that he...
He's doing a weekly call which starts every week on either on Saturday or Sunday, so that he has a maximum availability. And that's what driving the team I see. When they see their numbers on a weekly basis, they see that's going good in everything. Just give me one minute.
Yes.
Sorry, so he is regularly going over with the procedures and standards and that's helping the team as well. And I've seen this previously when I was handling a direct team where the team was working with me, I was working in shared knock.
Yeah.
It happens generally, like if we do not reiterate the process, sometimes they become reluctant in everything and then they miss out on the process. So they might be falling nine things out of 10, they might be missing out one. And it's with all the teams that this happens. So regular.
review of processes, reinforcing them, that really helps. Okay. And Manuj, they'll build a structured onboarding approach for onboarding new team members. He built a 90-60-90 plan for them so that we can onboard techs.
Correctly, on in a structured way, and that's really helping. We can see Sarah and Hector improving in a better way, and we already see that the experimentation worked in Kris, and he's...
Yes.
Good, even good output.
So improve ticket routing guidance and workflow efficiency across shifts. So that's again, manage ideas. And performance consistency, like the team knows where they are going down, when their performance is going up and down. So that is really helping them.
track their matrix. Plus I know Manuj has done one more thing. Also he has done on Saturday and Sunday, but I know the way he works. He has asked him to track their own matrix as well. So that they are using the Brij gauge and everything so that they know where they are lacking and.
they do not need guidance. And me and Manuj were discussing this last Friday. We want to make this team self-sustainable so that going forward in next couple of weeks or maybe months, we see that Manuj comes in normal shift.
Yeah.
every day, putting in deep checks, checking if everything is going right or not. So that's our goal moving forward.
So, Kaila, I want to know one thing.
Once the team gets stable, they are familiar with the process and everything, Manuj is taking care of that, all the things. What's next for Manuj?
Gonna replace me, I'm gonna quit.
No, you, you, you, you have a different role as well, so he's not gonna replace you, but yes, what's additional coming in from Manuj?
Yeah.
Um...
Like he's doing fantastic where he is right now. Like he's really saving me from being the one in 24 hours because he's just as crazy as me and there all the time.
I don't know, like refining process more.
I would see growing the team in the near future, but that's going to be at least a few months down the road, but he's going to have a few more people to look after.
Um...
I don't know.
Mark, what do you want to do? Where do you want to go from where you're at?
Let's.
Sure.
Projects, projects.
You want to deal with projects?
Send me to project. Yeah, send me to onboardings.
Project Manager.
That would probably...
be a drastic improvement to what's going on right now.
Right, data speaks for itself.
Yeah, but before we move ahead with that, Manuj, what I say is...
Consistency is the key. Once we see that this is consistently happening, then we can look at it. I am talking not about the near future, I'm talking about the future that's there in next three to six months for you. That is, we'll see where it takes you. Next, I want to talk about Hersh.
Yeah.
Mm.
Uhh...
That's one area that we want to discuss. He has completed his training and everything. He was able to successfully upgrade himself. Now what's next for him? Should we, and he has been technically doing very good in terms of his learning and everything. He just needs a...
real-time experience while working on the tickets. Should we start using him in after hours or should we propose him to an IST and then obviously bring in another?
Dispatcher who takes care of his work.
For the time being, like once we get the team stabilized, hopefully Vince is good. Harish is doing, I touch base with him periodically. And yeah, it sounds like he's doing good, getting up to where he needs to be.
We can likely start looking at either moving him into an IST or onto the after hours team. And then we would need to backfill his.
His triage position, um, if they do that.
Yeah.
Yeah, what?
So he's completely done all his training now?
Yes, he's done. And my next step was you said that you would review him technically. So that's one thing I want because we reviewed him technically, not me, but in another tier from another location, reviewed him and he was able to clear his level of assessment as well. But
Okay.
Yeah.
I want you to do it from an Atul perspective.
Okay, good.
I'll schedule.
Basically an interview. I'll run through my tricky question list that confuses a lot of people. We'll see how he does this. Now he didn't do bad the first time. Did a little more training and by the sounds of it, if he's all done on your side.
Yeah.
Mm.
that we can start looking at shuffling him out of triage and into a more technical role. So I'll get that scheduled possibly for tomorrow. I'll see what my schedule looks like. We'll get it done sooner than later, and then we can see where we can move them.
Yeah.
Thank you for that. Moving on next, no to do from previous meeting, performance analysis, utilization overall looks good. As I said, like everyone is crossing the mark of 80%. That was our end goal and few people are already reaching above 90%. Thanks, Kumar.
for bringing the consistency in the team.
Mhm.
Thanks, Seamus. For a minute, your graph, I was like, what? But no, no, it makes perfect sense now. Yeah, if you look at it, Kyle, for the month of April, that's in blue, right? Kane was with me. Kris, he was halfway there.
Okay.
Yes.
Let's keep it that way, right? And then same goes for Sarah. She was under the onboarding phase, right? Ryder had a few PTOs and some sick leaves. So that's why he's a bit on the left side, on the lower side, I should say.
And.
Kip.
Mhm.
But you should see improvement overall, right? That this is kind of my report card, so Sharma, sorry for taking over the call, but yes, right, we are actively.
Yeah.
But overall we can see the upward trend as well for all the employees. So that's...
Absolutely, absolutely. Yeah, Kyle, if we talk about...
Yeah.
Mike, there's always going to be some up and down, but this past month, everybody's over the 80, which is fantastic. Hector's first month in is already over 80%. So, and that's going to come down to the onboarding program that you've got for everybody there, Mark.
Correct, correct. Yeah, so...
So, good job on that.
There's already hitting ninety-nine, like we're we're we're doing it.
Absolutely, absolutely. Seamus, I think when you built this presentation of yours, right, you will see improvement on Hector's side as well.
I have moved, Kyle, this is just FYI for you and Seamus. I've moved Sarah down to the 1pm to 10pm Eastern shift so that everything that she has learned with me while working with me in the 6 to 3 prime shift, she's going to convey and pass on all the information plus hold Hector's hand.
to get him up to speed in the process, not on getting the numbers back up, but just on the process side. Seamus, I think you are not aware about this, but one of the T3s, Stephen, there was some misunderstanding when Hector reached out for help and he wasn't sure about the process.
Mm.
process. Of course, he was new. He got confused between the how to contact a T3, right? So I've shared feedback with him as well. And like I said, Kyle, we spoke about this on Monday as well. You will see improvements starting next week or actually.
They are coming back in the same shift tomorrow, right? Yeah, you would see improvement tomorrow.
Anand.
Not this week.
And I am okay with the process misses happening with the newer techs because they will learn with the misses as well. We cannot see everything picture perfect. You like it that way, but I know if everything is picture perfect, it's a watermelon effect.
Yeah.
Nobody's going to be perfect out of the gate. It's his first month. He's already over 80%. So he's done good on his utilization right out of the gate.
Yes.
Alright, alright.
So that's a win right there. As long as he keeps it up. Yeah, there's some process misses, but like Seamus said, like it will help them learn.
Bill.
Cool.
Yeah.
Thanks, Seamus.
Moving on next, for the ticket closures, Hector, we know like he was below the targets. He started on 9th May, so that he was obviously less. Kane, Kris, Rattan, Ryder, and Sarah, all are going good. So again, the ticket count varies month to month. We cannot put in a consistency because again.
Mm.
Yeah.
When the shift changes, somebody is between 8 and 5, obviously their ticket counts will be less because they would be working on EPDR project. And again, they might not be able to close the tickets because users might not be available, they might not talk to them, and they might call back the IST. So again, we know like this.
Yes.
Trained, we would see up and down.
Yeah. The ticket closures, as long as they hit their time and they're not padding time, which we do, we check for, I know they're not because we check it. But as long as they're hitting their time,
And again.
Vikram.
They can't tell the time Manuj is there, they can't.
Ticket closures, yeah, it's going to struggle sometimes. They also have fun with the EPDR tickets because the board that they're on doesn't have the background workflow to allow them to complete the tickets.
So we need to go through those and then I can close them for them, which they still get credit for the close, but.
A lot of those also drag along because they had time, they work on it, things are getting done, but some of them, they just, right, so they don't get closed right away. Sometimes some devices, we're actually working on clearing out some of the backlog on those for devices that have been offline for 90 days.
We're just popping those out of enable. We can easily put them back in if somebody calls in from that device. But that'll allow for more closures. So some of these closure numbers are going to go up.
This month.
Sure.
Moving on next, CSAT, everyone at 100%, Hector 2 service, first month 2 service, that's great. Gain for, Crayshade, Rita for, Ripintent, Sarah 3, one DSAT. Yeah, obviously it was a mess. It was an regular account lock.
Yeah.
Yep.
It could have been handled a different way, but yes, we understand the users frustration and.
It's entirely possible that regardless of, even if she fixed it in 5 minutes, she quite possibly still could have gotten a desat on that. That user's been frustrated for a while by the sounds of it, so.
Yes.
Again, I'm not concerned about that DSAT.
Same. Moving in next, leaves overall, this is the leaves unplanned. We can see the number has gone down relatively. So Hector 1, Sarah 1 and Rita 1 rest all are good. So upcoming leaves crash is on 25th to 29th June, Sarah 2nd, 3rd and 4th July.
I guess the last leaves are denied like 15, 18, and 19. Those are denied, Kyle, correct?
Well, that's 100% denied because they're also wrong.
He changed it this morning. He tried to change it this morning.
No.
Lee.
I guess.
Okay, it's 14th, 15th, and 18th.
I haven't talked to him about it.
OK, yeah.
The deck is prepared in advance, so, and again, we...
Yeah.
Yeah, it was this morning that he changed it, so it's...
Right.
And again, we had a strategy meet that went for three, 3 1/2 hours. Then there was, I had a call with Titan. Nick is really happy. He had a lot of team movements happening and then a recent tech joint and that's working really well for him. Rimal.
Mark, for your knowledge, he recently joined, and...
He is doing great, so that's why Nick and that took out my time as well.
Excellent.
So.
I'll I have those details, I'll update in my tracker as well.
Yeah.
I haven't spoken to Mark about it yet, but it's all denied.
Oh.
Ha.
Moving on next way forward, like before moving to way forward, I wanted to ask like Kyle, if there is any tech who wants to work in IST and who does not want to work in after hours because of the rotational shifts and everything. Maybe, and it's a preference that they want to grow into that specific area.
No.
Yeah, so...
Should we look into that? Or should we, how should we approach it? I just want to know from your angle, how should we do it?
If we're going to start going down that road where people want to transition out into ISTs, we need to be able to backfill them well before they transition out so that we don't get left in an 8 tech when the 9 is what we need. Like we're doing surprisingly well. No, no, no. If they want to transfer out.
Yes.
No, I was just asking.
You and I see.
It's a growth opportunity, absolutely, for them. So if that's something that they're interested in, it's definitely something we can look at.
But again, as long as we have the lead time, the backfill and get the new person up to speed before anybody leaves.
Like, I...
Yeah, so I would be very specific in this. So what we'll do in case this happens, if any text registers his interest in moving to NIST, our simple process would be that we will align some person before.
there would be a complete transition of one or two months and then he can move on to an IST. Also, this depends if there is an open position in an IST, these two factors. Mark, you want to add anything?
Yes.
Is.
I think you answered 50% of my my.
Thoughts, right? But have we done this in the past, Kyle? Is it a frequent thing where people move?
No.
It, it hasn't happened before.
Yeah, this has happened before, wherein the dispatch team moved into access team and then access team, when it got dismantled, they moved into tech and again, access team from access team, people used to move into IST. That has happened. I guess Ian and Russell, they were initially in dispatch team.
Yeah.
They were triaged when we had the techs, one tech per region for the after hours. Jain and Russell would essentially triage overnight.
And then they moved into...
and then it would go to the tax. They worked on some tickets, but not a whole lot, some of the alerts.
But yeah, they transitioned in. We've never transitioned anybody out of the after hours team into an IST yet. Has anybody expressed any interest?
Would we consider?
Yeah.
Um...
Yes and no.
Not right now, Kyle, uh, so yeah.
Yeah, yeah, you and I are on the same page, Seamus. Like, we've sensed it, Kaila. It's more of a hunch that I have, right?
Mhm.
Okay, yeah. I was just curious if anybody voiced a thought of transitioning to an ISD. I'm not opposed to it. If that's something that they're interested in, absolutely. We just need to make sure that there's no drop in quality for the after hours.
To be honest, I...
Yeah.
Mhm.
Absolutely. No, absolutely. All this stemmed from my thought process and I went to Seamus that, hey, how would you like this idea if we propose it, right? If we try to run with it further, how far we would go. And that's why this conversation is coming into picture now. Right again.
No, no, absolutely.
Mhm.
Yeah.
Seamus is all about growth, right? Seamus is all about keeping both sides happy, right? And so am I. For me, my customers need to stay happy. That's how I see it. Okay, let's talk.
S.
One thing I would like to add, Manuj, like there was one scenario that happened. Now I'll tell you. Sam Arora, he was first interviewed by Mark, not Mark, I forgot his name, Matt.
Mhm.
Matt.
Yeah, Matt for access team. Now, he had interviewed Sam, he liked Sam, Sam when he onboarded with access team. He clearly said, I do not want to do this work.
Oh, okay.
Okay, and then he got interviewed with...
Jack steam, I forgot to.
Jack man, uh, IST Polaris.
Yes, any, no, no, no, Polaris is Jennifer.
Napolis.
I know which one.
Ah.
Jay, he's in Ontario.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah. So he was working there for almost a year. Then his health was not stable. So he moved out of F12 when he's not aligned with any of the partners we have. He's on bench trying to recover. So that was one of the things that has already happened.
because he clearly said, I do not want to do this work within the first week. And then it, Matt was super happy, Lakhwinder was super happy that, okay, we did not move forward. And then we put in some other person in place of, so.
Play.
Mm.
Again, Rudra was there who transitioned out of Jack's team and then she moved into Matt's team and then again he moved into Jack's team. So that was an interchange that happened.
Got it. Thank you.
Yeah, we've shuffled people before, just it's never happened with the after hours.
And it was a...
Yep.
Yeah.
Mark, remember this date, 23rd March, 2025. This is when After Hours came into force.
Really?
Yes, full-fledged, like complete after hours where we had seven, 6, 7 ticks covering complete after hours. Before that it was just Ian and Russell doing some of the after hours work, but complete ticket handling.
Yeah.
Taking calls and everything, and yeah, go like, and and we started off without any process, just small nits and bits and pieces, and post that when things when you came in there was a lot of processes that were built.
To go live.
The full go live.
There was a lot of trial and error at the start there.
Mm.
Right.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, so that's there.
Overall, so my Mark has said like his focus is to reduce the missed calls further. I know it cannot go less than 1% because I know the stats.
There's always going to be something and you can't touch anything. Yeah, there's always going to be something. As long as we keep it low, we do what we can. We call them back as soon as possible.
Yeah, every time it's going to be missed.
Yeah, we cannot.
Yeah.
Sage.
And I was talking to Mark regarding this. I said, okay, tell me one thing in order to do a resource planning.
Which dates?
of Saturday and Sunday or which dates of the month you see a heavy call flow and we need that data and we can analyze that. I'll help you do that. He said that I had already analyzed and there's no specific trend which I can find because sometimes it's Saturday, next week it's Sunday.
Stop.
Again, next week it can be Sunday and the last week can be Saturday. So we do not have any specific trend where we can say like, okay, we can increase the resources on Saturday or Sunday. But this is how things work. Sometimes we have to work on just, and that's where I come from. Like we cannot.
Yeah.
go below 1%, 1% is the minimum that we would be able to achieve. It can.
And Mike, you are very optimistic. I still say like not below 2%. And 2% is optimal in my case, because perfect state cannot be attained in operation.
We may get lucky and get the odd week where it's perfect, but for an entire month, I don't think we're ever going to get 0 missed calls. There's always going to be a couple.
It's, it's can be, it can be luck, it can be luck, but no, we cannot go below a certain percentage, and...
Vaid.
Just.
Being realistic is it's what I see.
But.
With the tech, with the team the way it is, we may get certain periods of the year, like December.
We could get a 0 missed call month because generally things start to slow down in December.
Yes.
We could get away with it.
It is possible. I don't think it's very likely on a regular basis. Coming into summer, we might also get lucky in July or August because a lot of people take vacations. They're not wanting to deal with anything. They want to go outside.
Enjoy the sun, so.
There's some periods of the year where we could get below that 2%. It's possible.
But I wouldn't bank on it.
He's not happy hearing that.
S.
Yeah.
But yes, see, I have seen this trend and not only MSP and I go back to enterprise as well.
Always the call abandon percentage or missed call percentage basically is that I've seen in large organizations, it's 10%. When I was in BPO, I would say working for a UK client, it was around 12%. In MSP.
Sure.
Yeah.
We are targeting 2 to 5, less than 5%, which is good. Again, you are being ambitious, trying to reduce 2%. If you can do it for consistently, six months, we all are happy. Me, Kai, you, Lakhwinder, everyone is happy. But don't let it take a toll on you, like.
Okay, it's gone to 2.5 percent. Oh, it has increased. Like, let's be realistic, this can happen.
Yeah.
But.
Yeah, don't let it hurt you. If you can get it below, fantastic. Everybody will cheer you on, but don't stress too much on.
No, I hear you.
OK.
Yeah.
Yes.
on fighting it. There's always going to be some misses. It's the nature of what it is. You could get, like when the data center had the issue, how many calls did we miss on that? Because the phone was just constantly ringing. There's nothing you can do. It is what it is. We know what the issue is.
Got it.
Yeah.
Exactly.
It's being worked on. We just have to catch as many calls as we can and call everybody back and let them know what's going on.
So.
We're gonna run into things like that. It's not the last time that that's gonna happen.
Hopefully it happens later at night when people don't notice, but...
We never know.
We never know when a vulnerability would hit. Like what was that vulnerability, Kyle, that hit? That was AV vulnerability where the systems started crashing. There was one antivirus.
Yeah.
Oh, the CrowdStrike.
Bit different.
Ohh yeah, crowd, right?
Yeah, CrowdStrike. Yeah, that had affected that that that affected one of the airlines. I do not remember that entire airlines had gone down for a couple of hours.
Where it took everybody down.
S.
Yeah.
Yeah, uh, yeah, that was really...
There was a whole lot of everything affected on that day.
And in that case, Mark, what would you have done? Your phone would have been constantly cleaning. You cannot ask like Team. Okay, you cannot take breaks for the next six hours. These things happen and we need to be ready for them as well.
Just stay patient.
Yup.
Yeah.
Okay. Performance consistency, that's our target. That's what we are looking forward to, that we need to sustain it at least three or four months where we see constant productivity happening. And focus is always on quality improvement.
Manuj is regularly doing coaching and development. That's helping the team. We have seen the growth. And the next thing that Manuj is working on so that he can be...
three of those regular checks and dip checks. So he's trying to develop a shift lead ownership wherein some key players have been identified where they would focus on handling the shift. It would be their responsibility. Again, it would serve them.
as a platform where they can grow, maybe as a TL or maybe as a senior leader or senior engineer who takes care of the leads, leadership. So that's there.
Mhm.
Yep.
Let's be honest, Mark's never going to stop his dip checks.
And last, but...
I was just being too optimistic.
Yeah, and yeah, like the last point, data-driven decision making, yeah, that would always stay there. Till the time mark is there, that was always be there.
data checks would be in place. Apart from this, anything Kyle you want to share with us? Anything specific?
I think we're moving in the right direction.
In the case of having to dismiss a tech in the future, we need to speed up the process for these interviews, I think. Because we're dragging a bit and we're making it work, but we need to keep that consistent nine people. I know it was a bit of a snap decision to dismiss, but...
Two.
I know.
We need to be more, just quicker on the replacement track. And I know you guys are trying to get us the best possible options, but...
Yeah.
Just need to be quick.
Yeah, Kyle, and honestly, it's not on Mark, it's on us. Even he did not knew like this sudden decision would be made by HR. So we were already trying to figure out a way to retain him. We could have done that, but there were some major issues because of which we could not do that.
Yeah.
Mm.
And that's where we lost the mark. But thankfully, we had already added Kris as a resource who would be there in these situations. So that helped us. But yes, we'll make sure any transition going forward, we'll have tech ready.
in advance before we move any of the text or before we commit any of the text that they can move into YST or anything. We'll definitely have a detailed plan and a strategy around it. It would not be random.
Mm.
Yeah, I also look back through the.
The tracking for the the.
text and he was kind of dragging the team down a bit. So it was probably the right decision. So they're like, if it needs to happen, it needs to happen. It is what it is. Just going forward, we need to make sure that we have somebody in the pipe that we can start interviewing and.
Correct.
Get that done as soon as possible.
No worries, we are going to meet with Vance in the next 13 minutes. Hopefully that should turn out good. He is a very sincere resource. He's working in offers as of now, and he committed on being present at 12 P.m. PST.
Yep.
Soap.
Okay.
Yeah, he should be there.
Excellent.
Okay.
You want me to be on that interview or?
Yeah, if you want to come in, absolutely.
Okay, I'll see.
So Mark, you drive, you start the recording and everything. I won't join since you're joining. You start the recording and everything.
Yeah, right. No, no, no, no, it doesn't work like that. It needs to get Seamus's seal of approval. He's a tough nut, Kyle. He's a tough nut, right?
Just gonna show up and click a button and run away.
Yeah.
No.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, you haven't been in any of the interviews, so I just need to start the recording, introduce, and then drop off. That's a criteria that F12 has said, like the anyone from ITBD cannot stay on the interview.
Yep.
Okay, makes sense now.
Since you are at 12, you can stay.
Yeah.
I would I would skip this one chance, right? Yeah, I'm gonna skip this one, right? Yeah, I I worked with him in the past for a few months, right? And I don't want to give out the impression, right?
You gonna skip it? Okay.
That's fine.
Okay, yeah, no, absolutely. Like, it's up to you if you want to join or not for any of the interviews. You're going to be dealing with them. Generally, I think you talk to them before I do.
So...
Right.
So you already have your opinion going into it. So yeah, that's absolutely fine.
Yeah, yeah.
Thank you. Cool. Then, that's all I had. Seamus, thank you so much for backing me up, Kyle. As always, please approve. Have advice.
Absolutely.
Put it into Dayforce.
No, those are not approved. I reject them as well.
You want me to put it into Dayforce? I'll do that. Okay.
Put in day for us, yep.
Kyle, just one quick query, like in Dayforce, is it for all? So I'll go with Manuj on this Manuj, just do one thing, just have a check, like if you can see all the F2V engineers which are from ITBD on Dayforce, no? It's only after us, that's their own.
No problems.
Mhm.
No.
I just see the after hours team and the triage team.
That's all I see.
Correct, and...
Okay.
And the escalation team, but...
In Day Force, no one reports to me. It has not been set up that way.
Yeah.
Okay, no, I just wanted to check because I see an inconsistency over here. Like after our team just put in their leaves and efforts, right, other people they might not be putting in. So just wanted to check if we have this.
Yeah, everybody should be putting it in through day force, whether they're in an IST or after hours.
Oh.
Yeah.
Everybody should be doing.
Okay.
Me and...
So we have the initial emails where we go, hey, did the user request, hey, can I get this time off? Yep, cool, go put it in Dayforce. And then I can approve it. It helps us track it on our side.
That's been an absolute nightmare to try and find the time off that they booked in Day Force, because it it touchy, but...
As long as we recorded in there, then everything's good.
OK.
Makes sense.
Okay, so in day force you can only see after I see not any other tech.
I can't see any of the ISD texts now.
Okay, great, thanks. I'll check with them one by one in that case.
Pre.
Ohh.
Awesome.
Thanks.
Thank you very much. We will check you.
Kour.
Have a great day ahead, Khan.
Yep, bye.
Thanks.